[Music]
6 26 city wednesday morning what's
driving crazy hey we're dropping some
traffic
lingo from an ordinary ramp closure so
the gist of a recent ndot press release
the closure of the southbound i-11 on
and off ramps at wagon wheel started a
couple of nights ago
scheduled to run from 8pm until 5am
nightly until april 8th but
it's the work that's being done that
provides a tiny peek into the wide world
of traffic besides just cars moving
around
ndot says the temporary closures are
needed for constructing
rip rap drainage channels alongside the
interchange now you've probably driven
by many examples of
rip rap without knowing that's what it's
called
wikipedia says rip-rap is human-placed
rock or other material that rip-raps are
used to armor shorelines and stream beds
and bridge abutments against erosion
you probably never stopped to think
about it other than maybe hey
nice rocks by this side of the road but
let me tell you a riprap
is a serious business they don't just
toss those rocks out there i found
dozens of 100 page documents with
diagrams crazy math equations
rip-rap who knew i'll be putting some of
those links on the online version of
this story at eightnewsnow.com click
traffic then driving me crazy buckle up
drive carefully please put on the phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8newsnow.com